okay let's now talk about polling Donald
Trump continues to collapse in the polls
and this should really scare us it
should really scare you the people who
want to remove Trump are the ones who
should be most scared by Donald Trump's
polling collapse and this I've decided I
can't not cover the polls because the
polls are remarkable in terms of how
they compare to polls in past election
so I can't not talk about the polls but
the framing has to be the polls should
scare us because they might keep people
home the anti-trump voter may become
complacent if they see too many of these
polls that show Joe Biden winning so the
polls are looking good for Joe Biden and
that should scare us because we don't
want anybody to stay home as a result
the only possible result of Joe Biden
polling well if we don't take this
approach is that some people who don't
like Trump will say I don't really need
to vote I'm just gonna stay home because
you don't need my vote Biden's going to
win and that's exactly what we need to
dissuade people from doing so let's take
a look at the latest national polls and
then some of the important state numbers
so nationally Joe Biden is leading
Donald Trump by an average of eight
point seven that's a big lead the polls
ranged from leads as small as four and
as large as 14 for Joe Biden with an
average of eight point seven these are
crazy numbers this is a much bigger lead
than Hillary Clinton had and that's why
this is scary to me because this can
change these could be off by the full
margin of error these polls could make
people think I don't need to vote we'll
get back to that looking at the
important battleground states we see
that Arizona has Biden up three and a
half Florida has Biden up five in
Michigan Biden is up seven and a half in
North Carolina Biden is up by three in
New Hampshire Biden's up by four and a
half there's a tie in Ohio a state that
Donald Trump won in 2016
in Pennsylvania and Wisconsin Joe Biden
is polling about six and a half points
ahead
these are obviously very good numbers
for Joe Biden if you start with the 2016
map and then flip to Biden the states
where he's now winning in the polls Joe
Biden wins easily with more than 330
electoral votes and that's why we should
be scared we cannot afford to have a
single person stay home because they
think Biden has your state in the bag
I'll give you an example and this is an
extreme example I vote in Massachusetts
Biden is currently winning in
Massachusetts by 31 points Trump is not
going to win in Massachusetts but you'd
be you had better be damn sure that I am
going to vote Massachusetts earlier this
week I told you has confirmed
vote-by-mail is available to everybody
and they will be sending out absentee
ballot applications to every registered
voter so that's my view in Massachusetts
where Biden's winning by 31 if you are
in any state I don't care what state
you're in you should imagine your vote
visualize your vote flipping the
election from Trump to Biden okay
imagine that that is the importance of
your vote if you knew you could be the
difference maker between your state
going to Trump and Biden I hope I hope
that you would go out and vote if you
want to have a say that's exactly how
you have a say so we're going to report
on polling I'm not going to ignore the
polling story because it is an
interesting story you know an incumbent
president with this low of an approval
rating just four months out that is news
and I'm not going to it would be weird
for me to do a daily show about mostly
about American politics and not talk
about that but the way I'm going to
couch it is we should be scared by these
numbers because the last thing we want
is horrible gut-wrenching disappointment
again on November 3rd or November 4th or
November 10th however long it takes to
count all of those votes that will be
coming in by mail we're going to
continue covering the polling and asking
for your thoughts on the david pakman
show Instagram page which is simply
david pakman show all one word on
Instagram also if you want to see video
people are loving this some people went
completely crazy
riding in the streets when I posted this
video on my personal Instagram there is
a video of me harvesting my two spicy
peppers these things are so crunchy you
will not believe it ok follow me on
instagram at david pakman we'll take a
quick break and be back right after this
privacy calm is one of our sponsors and
they're giving you $5.00 just for using
their free service at privacy calm slash
Pakman privacy's of service I've been
using for a while now I love it it saves
me a bunch of headaches it's completely
free and it's very quick to set up and
here's how it works
when you pay for something online or
over the phone instead of exposing your
real credit card number privacy lets you
generate virtual card numbers the
payments are withdrawn from your
checking account but your real card
number stays completely private and you
do it all with one click you can
autofill the card number in your web
browser on the phone you can create 12
virtual cards a month you can set
spending limits freeze them delete them
whenever you want I especially love it
for free trials where you need to give a
credit card number because I can destroy
the virtual card number as soon as I
give it to the company and I know I
won't be charged in the future if you're
ordering food over the phone why do I
need to give a restaurant my real card
number I don't have to companies don't
have to know who you are your real
credit card number is protected from the
data breaches that happen unfortunately
more often than we would like and it's
completely free they do have a paid
version with different tiers where you
can create more virtual credit card
numbers per month cash back rewards
extra security features but go ahead and
sign up for the free service it's a no
brainer companies can't charge you
unexpectedly you're protected from
identity theft it costs you nothing and
privacy is giving you five dollars to
spend just for signing up when you go to
privacy calm slash Pakman